peux quand même vous voit sur votre moto
elle regarde plus voir la photo de gars
qu'est ce que ça signifie d'être la
petite amie d'un garçon qui a une moto
il ya deux attitudes ou bien on aime les
motos soi même à ce moment là c'est
sûrement superbe
ou bien on déteste les machines mais à
ce moment là c'est catastrophique parce
qu'il ya une rivalité entre la grosse
machine et la petite dernière tandis que
les hommes sont amoureux de leur moto a
souvent est ce que vous êtes jalouses de
la photo de votre mari non non parce que
comme j'en fais aussi avec lui m'enfin
je serais jalouse président est au sol
et une fascination de la machinerie et
des bidules et des chaînes toutes les
voiries si son casque et un uniforme les
avons toujours aimé les uniformes
militaires l'on n'est plus militaire
alors c'est la moto et et puis voilà et
puis parce qu'il ya une notion vitesse
et d'excès
et danger les risques et on sent
également sévèrement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez passer une femme en moto il
ya de plus en plus de femmes qui
achètent les motoristes que vous pensez
je pense que c'est très très très très
très très bien moi j'ai toujours pensé
que le jour où les femmes admettront de
mettre le derrière sur une moto
l'accepterons voire même en feront la
moto soit sauvé
[Musique]
bâle roche on écrivait à moto une femme
écrivain moto ça surprend un peu
c'est à dire je suis très rarement moto
parce que au fond la moto de moi c'est
une histoire d'amour complètement raté
je crois que comme moi martin demar si
vous avez lu la motocyclette et qu'une
balade normalement constitué qu'elle eut
la motocyclette 2 mondial n'a qu'une
envie c'est savoir les sensations qu'on
peut avoir sur ce joujou de luxe et bien
je vous assure que quand j'ai acheté
cette moto je n'ai pas fait tout un
cinéma et c'est pas vrai ou pas du tout
la première fois j'ai pris ma moto dans
paris j'ai failli être écrasé par deux
camions qui sont venus sur moi je me
sentais une toute petite chose et je
vous assure j'ai jamais eu aussi peur de
ma vie pourquoi la moto stéphane audran
mais parce que moi j'ai peur en voiture
j'ai peur de conduire en voiture est
alors en moto gp racer je me pensais
qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya un syndrome
de la moto casque c'est uniquement à
snobisme de la moto c'est pas je suis
pas du tout moi je pense que je me suis
borné question je vois qu'il ya beaucoup
de jong hun sen des motos va il doit y
avoir une mode mais en même temps en
temps ça correspond à une nécessité dans
paris jean cazenave vous êtes sociologue
est ce que vous considérez l'amour de la
moto comme une maladie de notre époque
les psychanalystes parle du complexe
sado masochistes dijon si vous voulez et
qu'on est à la fois dominateur et de
dominé quand on fait de la moto on est
dominé par la machine beaucoup plus
qu'en voiture c'est peut-être de là que
vient la griserie on se sent
véritablement la proie de cet engin avec
lequel on fait corps totalement
et puis d'autre part la moto dont un
sentiment de puissance
si vous pouvez les femmes achètent elles
de plus en plus de moto il ya aussi la
recherche pour la femme de cette
virilité qui lui manque et par
conséquent dans ce sens car la la
la machine est le symbole de cette
puissance virile dont elle est privée à
la naissance
[Musique]
pub